what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm Warren Thompson
and it looks like Disney and Marvel
Studios could be shaking things up a
little bit a couple of days ago Disney
did a quarter three of 2023 earnings
presentation and they listed all of
their projects coming out until 2024 and
some Marvel Studios projects were not on
there implying that they could
unfortunately be delayed and if this is
true we have heard a little bit of news
on why exactly that could be now of
course right now we have things going on
like the strikes but that is not what we
are specifically talking about we have
heard recently from an Insider that one
Disney plus project might not be so good
Plus at the same time we are now hearing
from a pretty big Outlet The Hollywood
Reporter that Disney might actually be
setting up to sell to Apple we've talked
about this a few times in the past and a
lot of people thought well yes it is an
option but it probably isn't a
possibility Bob Iger probably won't want
us sell Disney and apple probably won't
want to buy Disney because they have
stated before they wouldn't want to buy
a film studio however as this article by
The Hollywood Reporter States yes it's
true Apple would not want to buy a
studio but they would want to buy this
studio Disney isn't just another Studio
they are a Powerhouse they are the
leader they have so many different
properties they have Marvel Studios they
have lucasfilm Pixar and so many other
projects that are of Great Value and one
could see how Apple would want to buy
that especially since they have their
Apple TV now but don't worry we'll break
down the article and what you need to
know in this video and if you're new be
sure to subscribe so you don't miss out
on any of the latest news and if you
subscribe and leave a comment below your
automatically entered in our giveaway
for a chance to win an Xbox series X a
PS5 some Marvel Legends items or some DC
items winner gets to pick one item and
we pick a winner at the end of each
month so first things first let's talk
about a possible change in the Marvel
Phase 5 slate it looks like as a couple
of days ago Marvel has delayed a couple
of projects like I mentioned Disney
released their quarter 3 report and on
this and I'll put the link down below so
everybody can see it but on this report
there is a slide that says upcoming
theatrical releases key upcoming Disney
plus and Hulu releases where it lists
everything that is coming out on the
upcoming theatrical releases it goes all
the way up till June 14th of 2024 and
the only Marvel project we have listed
on there is the Marvel scheduled for
November 10th of 2023 that means
Deadpool 3 could be delayed because
Deadpool 3 is supposed to come out May
3rd of 2024 that is the current release
date set however it's not found on here
they have snow white coming out March
22nd then they have Kingdom of the
Planet of the Apes which is 20th century
which they own coming out May 24th of
2024 and then Inside Out 2 coming out
June 14th no sign of Deadpool 3 implying
that it possibly got delayed now this is
one project that has been affected it by
the strikes the writer strike the actor
strike and we have heard reports in the
past that if they didn't get this
resolved soon and the strikes continued
for a little bit more than a month and
Deadpool 3 would have to eventually get
delayed and it looks like that could
possibly be what is happening here as
Marvel and Disney have not listed it so
that's a bummer however this only lists
up until June 14th of 2024 and let's say
the strikes go on for a little bit
longer maybe a couple of months well
hopefully that would mean Deadpool would
only be delayed for a couple of more
months that means it could come out in
July or August sometime not far after
the release date of May and Bob Iger of
Disney has recently expressed that he
wants to come to a deal as soon as
possible and the studios and the guilds
are about to meet again the
organizations are all getting together
and going to try to get a deal they've
been unsuccessful the past few times but
right now you know the studios want to
get things moving again because a lot of
delays are happening and this is a key
delay right here Deadpool 3. now of
course it does say subject to change and
even for the key upcoming Disney plus
and Hulu releases slide it does say list
is not exhaustive subject to change
basically what this means is they are
kind of doing this as a precaution they
are expecting Deadpool 3 to be delayed
because of the strikes but let's say if
they were to end the strikes next week
and they got everything back with
production and they finished filming and
everything they needed then they could
stick to that original release date of
May 3rd but like I mentioned there is
another Marvel project that is suffering
and that is the echo series on the key
upcoming Disney plus and Hulu releases
we don't see echo on there anywhere we
do see Loki season 2. it's listed on
there of course under Marvel Disney plus
and a scripted series unfortunately Echo
is nowhere to be found and the reason
for this delay could be very different
recently yesterday actually The Insider
account viewer Anon stated this in
response to a question is it that bad
referring to Echo viewer Anon tweeted I
hope it's not but all the rumor members
about what rough-shaped secret invasion
was and turned out to be true and
everyone's consistently said Echo is
much worse off now we have actually
heard some decent things about the echo
series however it isn't exactly the best
sign that Marvel Studios has decided to
release all of the episodes of echo at
once binge style they are not releasing
them per week on the release date every
single episode is getting released and
that could be a bad sign so that could
actually be why Echo is getting delayed
possibly they are going to make some
changes we even heard a rumor before
that Marvel Studios was possibly
thinking of scrapping the whole thing
altogether which again is not a very
good sign but since we have heard some
good things from some good insiders
let's hope that it is actually going to
be a good series but as of right now it
is not listed on the Disney release
schedule so this is probably going to be
delayed and hopefully if it is delayed
for these reasons they will do something
to try to make it better and hopefully
the strikes end soon because that's just
going going to keep pushing everything
back so if they continue we could get
more Marvel delays it looks like
Deadpool has already suffered Echoes
suffered luckily for us the Marvels and
Loki season 2 are still on track because
they have already been completed but
everything else coming up in Phase 5 or
phase six is in pre-production or
production right now that has to be put
to a halt so hopefully the strikes get
done pretty soon so we don't have
another delay in a whole entire slate
ship now of course like I mentioned some
other huge changes could possibly happen
if Disney sold to Apple The Hollywood
Reporter is reporting that this could
very well happen the title and the
headline for their article that they put
out a couple of days ago in the ninth
reads a Disney sail to Apple question
mark don't count it out this time they
actually think that Bob Iger is starting
to prep for a sale the article States a
few weeks before Bob Iger sat down for
that CNBC interview in which he said
Disney's linear TV networks like ABC and
FX may not be the core or to the
company's business a veteran Hollywood
executive mused to The Hollywood
Reporter on the possibility of a deal
that would rock the industry Apple
buying Disney it's an idea that keeps
being discussed even though many top
Executives have scoffed at it and many
still do Apple doesn't want to buy a
studio they say and there's no way the
feds would allow a huge deal like that
to go through however the Observer
wasn't so quick to rule it out stating I
don't think Apple would buy the company
as it presently exist he said but if you
see Bob start to divest things that
feels like he's prepping for a sale and
there's clearly no buyer like apple and
that's exactly what Bob Iger started to
do he started to say that they might
start selling parts of Disney to other
Studios so it seems like he has begun
slimming down Disney and this Insider
states that that could be a possible
sign that he is prepping to sell the
company to Apple they also do state that
while it may be very true that Apple
doesn't want to buy a studio maybe it
would want to buy this studio the one
that despite the challenges of the
moment has a vault full of Priceless IP
and Remains the most valuable brand in
entertainment plus not to mention Disney
and apple do have a relationship with
each other it's kind of a special
relationship as The Hollywood Reporter
States they State Steve Jobs founder and
creator of Apple of course served on
Disney's board of directors from 2006
until his death in 2011 and then Bob
Iger joined Apple's board shortly after
Steve Jobs died but he ended up
resigning from that position on
September 10 2019 which was
coincidentally the same day that Apple
officially announced that they were
going to get into the content business
through Apple TV so the current head of
Apple Bob Iger used to be a part of
Apple's board of directors that's a huge
relationship there Steve Jobs was also
on the board for Disney another huge
relationship and it does actually seem
like Bob Iger could be slimming down
Disney
according to these insiders in The
Hollywood Reporter that could mean
Disney is prepping for a sale obviously
if this happens it will shake up the
entire industry and of course would
result in apple owning Marvel Studios
and that alone could be a huge drastic
change Apple could clear house and
decide to fire everybody that is
currently at Marvel Studios that could
include Kevin feige obviously we don't
know what would happen and this is
simply a possibility not a reality at
this point in time but go ahead and let
us know your thoughts about this down
below do you think it would be a good
thing or a really bad thing if Disney
sold to Apple and apple owned Marvel
Studios let us know your thoughts about
that in the comments down below and
don't forget to like the video and
subscribe and hit that notification Bell
so you don't miss out on any of the
latest news you can also follow us on
Instagram and Twitter as well and as
always thank you all so much for
watching woof woof